so many topics to touch on this morning
so we're joined by cbs news senior white
house and political correspondent ed
o'keefe he's in our washington bureau ed
uh good morning from the border to two
huge bills being discussed contentiously
a potential shutdown i think it's
dizzying for even those who cover
congress in the white house full-time
some of it comes to a head on monday
what is happening in washington
yeah well to paraphrase elvis a lot of
conversation very little action i think
is part of the problem here as they try
to sort out a host of issues
you know immigration uh you know just a
reminder again this week of how urgent
and acute that one is you continue to
see no progress on things like voting
rights and police reform these are
things the president promised to figure
out but with republicans and democrats
unable to agree on them it's likely
they're going to just linger in the next
year and become fodder for the
congressional elections the issue of
course is that there's all this urgent
financial economic related legislation
that has to get through and even there
they've got big disagreements
and ed jeff mentioned monday the house
is supposed to uh i'm sorry the senate
is supposed to take up the house pass
bill
on
the government shutdown what can you
tell us about what we may see in a vote
and what could come from it that's right
this is designed to try to keep the
lights on uh they're supposed to get
this done by the end of the fiscal year
at the end of the month the house passed
it the problem is in the senate you've
got to get republican support at least
10 votes from them right now they're not
planning to do that so this test vote on
the bill likely to fail which is going
to lead democrats that have to go back
and try to come up with something that
could get republican support by thursday
when the deadline happens we've had
shutdowns before in this city
it happens across the federal government
the difference this time of course is we
haven't had a shutdown during a pandemic
don't be surprised that democrats
continue to amplify that point in the
coming days to try to put some pressure
on republicans to get this part of the
equation taken care of
well both sides are also butting heads
over this issue of a new debt ceiling um
what do you expect to happen with regard
to that right remember the debt ceiling
is to you know increase the borrowing
limit on spending that's already been
approved and already happened
what's interesting in this case is while
democrats republicans have approved this
before you know often with a little bit
of debate this time republicans are
saying go ahead and raise it but don't
do it with our votes because ultimately
this is about democratic legislation and
democratic spending priorities that we
don't agree with the democrats turn
around and say no no no
this is to pay for things that you pass
during the trump years republicans
you've got to be on board with this this
is a tricky one and a little more risky
because it puts the nation's credit
rating at risk it puts our ability to
pay for all government operations at
risk as well part of what would happen
if that spending bill that dana
mentioned gets passed is they would
suspend this debt limit until december
to try to give it a few more months to
see if there's any way to come up with
an agreement but again even that's at
risk of not being able to pass which
means you know we're essentially uh
playing and risking the nation's
financial health as democrats and
republicans continue to disagree over
these issues
but so there's there's two bills here to
talk about right it's the there's the
bipartisan infrastructure bill 1.1
trillion and the partisan three and a
half trillion dollar bill as well to get
that passed democrats need all support
in the senate right and most in the
house what are the chances that happens
well and that's and that's what's
slowing this down this is why there's so
much conversation the first thing to
keep in mind is that the 3.5 trillion
dollar price tag likely gonna have to
come down you heard the president
mention 2.9 trillion dollars yesterday
that's a figure i've heard from
democrats as well even bringing it down
that little bit might be enough to
convince enough moderates to go along
with it we'll see
ultimately they they believe something
will be passed by the end of the year
because there's no hard deadline on it
but the longer this goes on the longer
the questions of do we even need it and
how much support will there be for it
breaking it all down for us in plain
speak thank you so much ed thank you